panachage nom masculin signifiant
mélange combinaison en langage électoral
le panachage vous autorise à rayer
certains nom d'une liste de candidats et
à les remplacé par ceux d'une autre
liste en lisse le panachage est donc au
dépouillement de scrutins de liste ce
que le parfait dosage entre la limonade
et la bière est au panacher un vrai
cass-etête et comme le panacher le
panachage est à consommer avec
modération pour avoir droit à un
panachage bien frais il fallait habiter
une commune de moins de 3500 âes le taux
d'alcoolémie pardon le nombre
d'habitants a été abaissé aujourd'hui
au-dessus de 1000 administrés le
panachage est lui-même rayé de la liste
certains diront qu'il est mort par où il
a pêché d'autres que cela permet plus de
sobriété dans les scrutins de liste
termer les rayures bifures et autres
ratures de nom des listiers qui ne vous
plaisent pas terminz les rajouts de nom
et les basses vengeances pour faire élir
votre voisin à peine candidat sous
prétexte qu'il a annexé depuis des mois
votre des broussailleuse fini le
folklore les psychodrames les tragédie
grec pastorale pour les prochaines
municipales les électeurs des communes
de plus de 1000 habitants vaut trop donc
pour des listes bloquées et toute
intrusion d'un ingrédient personnel à la
recette officiellement reconnue
invalidera le bulletin tout ça nous a
donné quand même un peu soif alors hop
un bon panag un bon panéchage bref nous
on va aller boire un coup